ciao a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fatti j
ci siamo tirati su turbo dismount
esperimento ragazzi è successo che hanno
aggiunto questo con l'ultimo
aggiornamento credo che miley cyrus si è
entrato a far parte di questo gioco in
tutti i sensi cioè fermi un attimo che a
mio avviso credetemi ragazzi non lo farò
non ha avuto parole quando ho visto sto
aggiornamento però voglio provare a fare
una cosa scusato in attimo perfetto
ragazze non sono sicuro che ha funzioni
però allora vediamo un attimo se quello
che riesco a fare qualche disastro con
con la palla la demolizione con miley
cyrus credo di sì a fatevi provare la
potenza di questo arnese perché credo
che ci sarà da divertirsi e ragazzi
stato è la madonna che partenza della ma
da chi già non so neanche che cazzo fa
non sono andare dritto non è che sto
facendo chissà che madonna mia parte
se non i movimenti stupendi che fa sono
fantasmi bello se il sesto gioco aveva
un minimo di senso prima l'ha perso e
credetemi ragazzi che nella mia vita non
avrei mai pensato di arrivare a certi
livelli
che cosa è successo perfetto mi sono
schiantato 10 punti ha detto ragazzi mi
dicono che miley si sa andare sulla moto
c'è questa cosa
torno sempre più convinto se poi ragazzi
la la cosa che mi fa morire di più e
lava è la faccia che fa gola è
bellissimo
porca [ __ ] casa come ti permetti
rovinarmi il make up può dirlo la
ragazzina autostrada perché devo morirci
su sta cosa dalla fermin attimo e belli
io mi sono innamorato di nuovo lì sto
gioco grazie a quella talmente sexy
ragazzi le macchine mi cadono ai piedi
questa una cosa bellissima
da troppo peccato sia finito mai visto
miley cyrus sono skate board ma una
faccia del tipo io non c'ho per ragazzi
cioè un pad ast cioè non c'ho parole se
riuscissi a fare un salto decente bello
questo fantastico stavo attuare che
hanno sulla sul camion è tutto tempo
tutto calcolato cioè l'ultima volta ho
cercato senza essere eccola
[Musica]
se lo fa ho cercato su turbo dismount
nel modo migliore aspetto c'è un'ala che
cazzo è successo che ho preso un muro
alla velocità della luce scusami morosa
mi è rimasto il manubrio però va bene
così poi non lo sapete ma quando tornite
miley vi osserva
[Musica]
il gol hound che cos'è sta roba non ho
visto l'ultima volta che hanno fermati a
fatemi andare con la palla demolizione
ragazzi non l'ho ancora vista credo non
a meno che non mi sbagli non ancora
fatta
il mio sogno è riuscire a beccare una
cazzo di macchina con se si gioca non
presa minchia che il disastro che lo ha
fatto ragazze ho realizzato il mio sogno
prima che madonna esploso tutto tratta
mi ami ha investito il mio stesso dire
grazie fantastica voglio voglio fare un
giro così no dai sei veramente all'apice
della tua sensualità amica mia voglio
capire un attimo dove siamo gli ong sono
la palla ma avete mai visto una scena
dove è scoperta pure immaginate tipo una
scena reale dove la gente vede miley per
strada su una una palla dalle milizie
c'è che è stato fatto a kevin love
ragazzi è fantastica se cosa non ha
frenato che ci ho trovato che ci sono
nuove pose sbandata ricchezza io credo
che questa sia la polla posa spider man
forse non lo so comunque miley non se
non sei gentile e buona educazione
essere seduti composti quando si viaggia
ecco perfetto buono il terreno vero
fantasmi guardatevi ragazzi che lei li
osserva sempre yeah yeah yeah queste
sommosse di lanzo a pirelli che non
siete altro io sono capace di danzare
nel modo migliore
che bello ragazze sono sono contenti
oddio forse caccia successo o loro
macchine a caso grande una che va in
auto e la madonna greca non vorrei dire
troppo fatto un salto in avanti
bellissimo stavo stavo posando per il
calendario è una cosa la posa più bella
mai vista
a quell'ora gennaio ragazzi che questo
questo e febbraio cioè tipo un secondo
prima di essere demolito dal camion prof
amo questo gioco oddio la macchina è
partita tipo alla madonna che cazzo è
successo a questo non ci è riuscito a
fare l'ultima volta prima no stavolta se
riesco con questo non dovrebbe spostarmi
nessuno crede ma sono io che demoliscono
mica gli altri credo è poi magari ecco
infatti non dovrebbero riuscire a farmi
un cazzo forse io ma con la palla da
demolizione magari sì sì c'è c'è
minchia che potenza non è che ce la
faccio non ci posso che lanciamo messo
anni l'ultima volta ma stavolta ce la
faccio subito vai così addio che cazzo
succede o demolito di tool [ __ ] una
volta è quella buona me lo sento
me lo sento
un [ __ ] cambiando arrivato lo stronzi
va beh certo è bellissimo ragazzi grazie
una macchina c'era fantastico posizioni
sempre più inquietanti maelle i
complimenti e meraviglioso la gancia
notaio sta cosa non hai rotto i [ __ ]
però che succede
la moto ragazza impazzita impazzita da
sola da sarda hai rotto i [ __ ] e
perfetto bravo voglio cercare di capire
un attimo no però dai non dovette
trattarmi maroni co dove sono andato a
finire uno finito dentro un cespuglio
fantastico ivi mac questo robot io che
cosa figlia ragazzi miei rotti i
[ __ ] prima ma [ __ ]
l'area è stata è stato più forte di me
come ti permetti così se ne posso
prendere cosa questo e il marzo non ho
parole per descrivere l'epicità di
quest'episodio che succede se ero tutto
tutto armi chiama mi ferma nessuno
non mi ferma nessuno vai l'ultima no non
ci credo fa ho fatto un chilometro
facendo un calendario tra l'altro mentre
demolisco macchine non sono arrivato
alla fine devi toglierti ciò è brava si
no
molly dei dissestati attaccata non
perdere la testa provo con questo perché
il prossimo anno non ci voglio veramente
credere madonna e gli schiaffi che ti
tiro jughead beh ragazzi sto facendo dei
360 costa roba che non sono anch'io come
la roba va beh ovviamente col culo sul
perché diavolo il mio veicolo ha tentato
di aggrapparsi un albero madonna non
riesce andare dritto e tu secondo
proprio che cazzo fatto cioè il
traguardo e dall'altra parte con che non
trovo array dire però va bene lo stesso
di ragazzi non è possibile facciamo
grande fautore cambio perché lì non
riuscirò mai a fare quello sì ma abbiamo
mai un livello solo ti prego uno solo
per favore sì sì sì una sega demolito
tutto tutto il demolibile grazie fantasy
mira ancora una finta così perfetto no
the bridge ed è bellissimo ragazzi hanno
non è quello che penso che regala non
state vedendo anche voi
quanto il diavolo sta pilotando quella
fare forse la macchina volante di ron
credo e non ne sono sicura provate a
vado avanti lo stesso piuttosto
demolendo si aggancia posso fare
mio dio cioè la prima persona nel mondo
essersi fatta un ponte all'esterno
chiesto guardi così che sono fighi e
sondare sullo skate resto lo sapevo ti
guardi così io sto cercando di aiutarli
a fare con la faccia ecco vedi succedono
queste cose conosco il kung fu e non ho
paura di usarlo ho visto che tu sappia
guidare un camion dei pompieri miley
però non è che non mi fido va bene così
ecco fantastico dall'altro firth
bellissima curata complimenti forse così
non so se vado più storto four non lo so
sì sì ecco perfetto
mio zio che cavolo che vanta ecco che
sono sci sono uscito sono uscite non è
che ho avuto un affetto improvviso per i
cartelloni quindi ho voluto abbracciarlo
che i ragazzi questa queste tipo gandalf
il tipo tu non puoi passare o buttato
giù un albero bellissimo miley 66
perfetta è un suicidio però che succede
ho pagato
non so il perfetto grazie meraviglia non
ho capito che cosa è uscito dalla sedia
però ragazzi io e miley direi che
possiamo concludere che un episodio
adesso con il talk in finale ragazzi se
il video è piaciuto come sei falso
documento mi piace anche a valiani
facebook che come noi video tra tale
sezione senza avere sidis catherine ci
vediamo al prossimo vito della ragazzina